what does the Bible say about Christmas
celebration oh absolutely
nothing
absolutely nothing now that does not
mean I condemn those who celebrate
Christmas we have a lot of information
in El's writings about Christmas she
does not condemn having a Christmas tree
she recommends put gifts on the tree for
other people not for you I know you
don't like that but that's the way we
are she said put gifts on the tree for
other people it's a good time to remind
people of Jes Jesus she does not condemn
it but you need to understand no one
knows when Christ was
born all we know is he was born so we're
happy for that the Christmas season
excellent time to evangelize because the
baby in the manger is on everybody's
mind but you don't have to celebrate
Christmas it is not you know as a matter
of fact let's name some holidays
Christmas give me another one Easter
give me another
one Valentine's Day uh-huh give me
another one
Mother's day God bless all mothers
Father's Day there's one in the US
called sweetest day we have all these
days Ash Wednesday Good Friday Holy
Thursday Unholy Tuesday we have all
these days are you with me the only day
God wants tell me that day the Sabbath I
I'm talking to myself the only day God
wants is the Sabbath and we come to God
and we say well wait a minute father how
about Christmas God says no how about
Easter no Ash Wednesday no uh Good
Friday
no uh Mother's Day no Father's Day no
uncle's day no no
no what do you want the
Sabbath that's all we give him every
other day except the day he wants I must
break God's heart what's wrong with
these people